HEEEEY Le tour de magie de début de vidéo il vous a plu ?
Les amis aujourd'hui on va parler d'une théorie encore une fois j'adore j'adore ça ça me passionne on a commencé par parler des reptiliens
puis on a parlé de l'intelligence artificielle,
c'était intéressant en se disant que éventuellement, elles allaient dominer le monde les petites d'intelligences artificielles.
Puis on a parlé de la zone 51
et des aliens qui sont peut-être, ou peut-être pas la bas !
Je le rappelle tout ça c'est des théories,
il n'y a rien qui prouve que c'est vrai, rien qui prouve que c'est faux, je préfère désamorcer une fois de plus
voilà que les gens prennent pas trop ce truc au sérieux
parce que j'ai reçu des mails de gens qu'ils soupçonnaient leur prof d'être un reptilien
et qui m'en parlait en mode hyper sérieux...
C'est des théories, attention !
Les amis maintenant on arrête de parler, on arrête les conneries, on rentre dans le coeur du sujet.
Ce qui est cool avec cette théorie c'est qu'elle est très récente, elle date de un mois
je voulais faire vidéo avant, mais je pouvais pas parce qu'il n'y avait pas encore tous les éléments ect.
et j'aurais pas pu raconter le truc bien.
Maintenant je peux, c'est passé.
Ça a commencé le 13 mars, sur Twitter,
Lorsqu'un utilisateur,
comme vous, comme moi
a partagé un message vocal trop bizarre qu'il a reçu sur son téléphone.
peut-être avez-vous suivi cette histoire ou pas je sais pas moi en tout cas j'ai suivi grâce à quelqu'un qui m'a mentionné à ce moment
peut-être avez-vous suivi cette histoire ou pas, je sais pas,
moi en tout cas j'ai suivi grâce à quelqu'un qui m'a mentionné à ce moment là,
et qui m'a dit : Lucas, intéresse toi à ce truc, je suis sûr tu va kiffer.
et qui m'a dit , Lucas intéresse toi à ce truc , je suis sùr tu va kiffer .
Il a vu juste !
Il a vu juste et il me connait bien
il me connait bien, il me connaît mieux que ma maman cet homme.
il me connait mieux que ma maman ce Tom hein Paul ou Julien je sais plus trop ton nom, peut-être Thierry bref le 13 mars
Paul
ou Julien,
J'sais plus trop ton nom
Peut-être Tierry
Bref, le 13 mars,
un utilisateur du nom de Ty,
un utilisateur du nom de Ty
demande de l'aide aux twittos pour déchiffrer un message vocal trop bizarre qu'il vient de recevoir alors ce message vocal
demande de l'aide aux tweetos aux pour déchiffrer un message vocal trop bizarre qui vient de recevoir.
alors ce message vocal,
qu'est-ce qu'il raconte ?
bien, écoutons le ensemble
N'est ce pas creepy ?
sans déconner, imaginez vous recevoir ce message sur votre boîte mail
moi j'aurais fait comme Ty, et j'aurais partagé sur Twitter,
j'aurais dit :
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ! Qu'est-ce qui m'arrive ?
alors les twittos se sont immédiatement intéressé a son tweet, il y a eu plus de 150 000 RTs sur son truc,
parce que tout le monde s'est dit ;
what the fuck ? Qu'est-ce que c'est que ce bordel ?
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce bordel le message utilise l'alphabet phonétique de l'otan c'est ce qui est entre autres utilisé pour les communications
Le message utilise l'alphabet phonétique de l'otan, c'est ce qui est entre autres utilisé pour les communications radio parfois.
C'est un truc est utilisée normalement surtout par l'armée ou les secours, la police.
Pour le déchiffrer c'est assez simple
En gros, faut juste garder la première lettre de chaque mot, et ça te donne d'autres mots
Voilà par exemple, j'sais pas moi
Pour dire Squeezie, tu dis ;
Voilà, ça fait Squeezie.
Okay, je vais pas vous faire travailler aujourd'hui, vous pouvez ranger les stylos et les cahiers.
Ty a déchiffré le message vocal pour nous, et ça donne :
Danger SOS it is dire for you to evacuate be cautious they are not human SOS danger SOS
*lecture du tweet*
Ce qui en français, nous donne :
Ce qui en français nous donne :
Danger SOS il est urgent* pour vous d'évacuer soyez prudents ils ne sont pas humains SOS danger SOS
*lecture du tweet*
Je change d'opérateur !
Tout de suite !
Jusque là, on peut se dire, putain c'est un canular
ce n'est pas le seul à avoir reçu énormément de gens dû le recevoir ça fait peur mais voilà bon bien jouer la blague juste
j'suis pas le seul à avoir reçu, énormément d'autres gens on dû le recevoir, ça fait peur,
mais voilà bon, bien joué la blague
Juste là, moi je trouvais ça dingue que des gens prennent le temps de mettre au point des blagues de genre là,
qui font vraiment flipper les autres quoi,
c'est vraiment pas gentil du tout comme blague, c'est l'inverse d'une blague mon gars.
Dans le message, à la fin il ya aussi une série de chiffres
Et généralement, une serie de chiffre c'est forcément un truc à déchiffrer, ça se balance pas comme ça, ça signifie forcément quelque chose.
Alors les tweetos, ces bons tweetos qui ont flaire, qui ont l'enquète dans le sang
qui on trop regardé Derrick
Eh bien ils enquêtent mon gars, et ils enquêtent très très bien putain.
Une tweetos du nom de Erin Mahoney (@ErMahoney6)
J'espère que j'écorche pas son nom,
de toute façon elle n'est pas française, je m'en bats les couilles, elle ne tombera jamais sur cette vidéo.
Bref, elle a eu l'idée de taper les chiffres dans Google Maps
Comme si c'était des coordonnées,
et il se trouve que ça donne à un endroit
TRÈS proche de celui, où on a perdu le contact avec le vol numéro 370 de Malaysia Airlines.
Le fameux avion qui a disparu
J'sais pas si vous avez entendu parler de cette histoire
C'est un truc de malade
C'est un mystère total, ça c'est passé en 2014
Et à l'heure actuelle, on a retrouvé quelques débris